I can't think with all the background noise.
Ah, White noise.
Hey everyone!
Amy with you on DNews today.
* To understand how white noise helps you
sleep, we need to take a quick step back and
look at how sound and hearing work first.
Sound is a wave that moves through the air,
vibrating molecules as it goes along.
The vibrations hit the eardrums then pass
through to the inner ear where cells called
hair cells change the vibrations into electrical
signals.
These signals go to the brain and tell you
what sound you’re hearing.
The frequency of that wave — technically
speaking, how often the particles’ vibrations
repeat in one second — is measured in hertz.
Humans can hear sounds from 20 hertz to 20,000
hertz, and the higher the frequency the higher
the note you hear, and also the less easy
it is to ignore.
And these hearing faculties still work when
you’re sleeping; even if you’re not awake,
your brain can register significant sounds.
So when you hear noise at night and it wakes
you up, it’s the sudden change in frequency
of background noise that disturbs your sleeping
brain.
So how can you stop those sudden frequency
sounds from ripping you out of dreamland?
We’re back to white noise.
White noise, properly speaking, is a constant
noise that covers all hearable frequencies
at once at a constant power rate per hertz.
It’s frequency spectrum is completely flat,
so no new sounds can be heard over it… if
it’s playing loud enough, of course.
White noise essentially masks all other sounds.
And that’s where it gets its name.
White noise is analogous to white light: white
light is all wavelengths of light and white
noise is all frequencies of sound.
So because it’s characterized as constant
noise with equal power across all frequencies,
that means some sounds that people call white
noise aren’t.
The hum of an engine, for example, or the
pitter patter of rainfall.
They’re soothing sounds that block out some
noise, but they aren’t true white noise.
But white isn’t the only colour of sound.
There are others, and like how coloured light
is a specific wavelength, colours of noise
focus on specific frequencies.
And some research suggests that pink noise
is actually a better sleep sound than white
noise.
Like white noise, pink noise contains all
frequencies audible to humans ears, but the
power per hertz decreases as the frequency
increases.
It’s a subtle difference.
So here’s what white noise sounds like:
And here’s what pink noise sounds like:
And when you play them back to back, you can
hear the difference:
In a small study of 11 subjects, a team of
German researchers played pink noise in synchronicity
with sleeping subjects’ brain rhythms.
When compared to a control that had no sound
stimulation, the pink noise seemed to prolong
deep sleep and enhance memory retention in
the morning.
There are other colours of noise, too, corresponding
to different frequencies like how coloured
light focuses on different wavelengths.
There’s red or brown noise, blue noise,
violet, black, green, and orange noise, though
I didn’t find any research about how well
they help you sleep.
So why do we find white noise soothing?
Well, it’s a personal preference thing.
Some people love white noise and some hate
it, but most people find it helpful for sleep
because of it’s ability to mask other sounds.
And really, don’t we all want a nice, quiet
night’s sleep?
Sound is pretty neat, and because it’s a
physical wave it can do some weird things.
Trace talks about some of the amazing things
sounds waves can do in this video right here.
Do you guys love or hate sleeping with white
noise?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe to DNews so you never
miss an episode.